safety measures at ccsd schools remain a
concern for parents a kindergartner went
missing on the first day of school when
pick-up procedures failed candace
charles joins us live from bendorf
elementary in spring valley with what
the parents did next candace
good evening kirsten evening folks now
this is where the school lets out right
over here the students come out of that
gate right on that gate there there's a
sign asking family members to remain
behind the gate but that did not happen
and cause chaos chaos that
kindergartener got lost in when her
parents tried to pick her up on her
first day of school
anybody could walk through
grab a kid
and walk right out the first week of
school comes with challenges but for
this parent it came with an extra amount
of fear that freak out moment is
unbearably scary lonnie and justin
guendov dropped their daughter emily off
at patricia benford elementary school
for her first day of school but tell me
they were already concerned in
the two days of
the orientation and the first day of
school i have received four separate
sets of instructions on where i would be
picking up my daughter for kindergarten
when they returned to pick her up they
said the drop-off area was a mad house
there's no checks or balances period
anybody could have walked into the open
gates and they did this was the
playground on the first day of school
during pickup there's a sign outside the
gates asking parents picking up their
children to stay outside the gate and
present a card like this one to pick up
their child we see one other parent
holding
a colored card and no emily her parents
became frantic asking the staff to radio
for help they've
misplaced
my child
on her very first day
of her very first year
of public school thankfully jessica
located emily she was near the exit gate
but for the family it was the last straw
we have already withdrawn our child the
gandles hope a better dismissal policy
will be put in place before the worst
happens i don't ever want this to happen
and i feel the school very very poorly
addressed the situation
now this is where the kindergarten
student pickup was last year that was
changed to an all-grade level pickup
area right down here due to the
kindergarten classes being remodeled now
unfortunately what's on the website has
not been updated to go along with those
details for now live in spring valley
i'm candice charles 8 news now